microsoft just released their surface
pro 8 which is an amazing machine but
can it stack up to apple's ipad pro with
the m1 chip so today we will compare
every single difference and see which
one of these devices you should buy
we're gonna take a look at everything
from the display the webcam the
microphones the keyboard covers using
the pens with them cpu and graphics
performance prices and more right off of
the bat i could tell that this surface
is a lot heavier even though the sizes
are fairly similar it is thicker and it
is packing a lot including a fan inside
of this machine it has vents all along
here for airflow and then of course it
has microsoft's little kickstand cover
so even without a keyboard cover or a
case you can adjust it if you want a
nice angle for drawing watching movies
stuff like that whereas the ipad you
have to buy their accessory as far as
ports microsoft definitely has apple
beat instead of having one thunderbolt
port on the bottom which is amazing for
the m1 we have two thunderbolt ports on
one side plus we have microsoft surface
connector for charging for using docks
and things like that and on the other
side we still have a headphone jack
which you don't get on the ipad pro and
not only that there is another secret
underneath this kickstand you guys can
see there's a little slot right here and
what that slot is you can actually open
it up and you can upgrade the ssd later
down the line so unlike the ipad pro if
you didn't buy enough capacity out of
the get go you are not stuck you can
actually upgrade it which is amazing now
we also have some major camera
differences both of them do have cameras
on the back and the surface has a 10
megapixel camera compared to look at
that module on the ipad pro which also
has an ultra wide now here are some shot
differences with the rear cameras um it
looks pretty noticeable when i took the
images you guys let me know your
thoughts down below and then of course
you can also shoot ultra wide so here is
that sample now on the front both of
these do have uh cameras the ipad is
oriented in a portrait mode just like a
standard ipad and here are a couple
sample images between them the surface
only has a five megapixel camera whereas
our ipad has that center stage feature
which it's cropping in when it's just me
and then vadim is going to go ahead and
enter the frame
and then now bam you guys can see right
there you guys better subscribe right
now
ultra wide and then the video is going
to step out
bam it zoomed back in so that part of it
is great and then of course with that if
you want to take some ultra wide shots
check this out
bam look at that that is insane you have
that ultra wide capability now we're
also going to compare the microphone
quality and the webcam use in just a bit
but first let's go ahead and bust out
the keyboards microsoft has a new
keyboard which has a slot for their pen
that can actually magnetically charge
the pen they'll attach it and charge it
which is great it also connects the same
way as before
whereas with apple we have this magic
keyboard now i know i mentioned that the
prices were the same
from the actual tablets themselves but
once you factor in the magic keyboard
and the apple pencil which attaches at
the top that's a big price difference it
costs 480 bucks for the apple pencil 2
and apple's magic keyboard compared to
280 for microsoft's premium signature
cover with this alcantara which is
really nice and then with that pen that
now features haptic feedback inside it
as well so you definitely save some
money going with microsoft's option now
as far as these keyboard covers
themselves i love how the magic keyboard
has this hinge so your screen floats
it's closer to you you can adjust it and
the overall feel how sturdy it is it's
not going to flop around if you're using
it on your lap with microsoft's cover
it's a lot more floppy you have a
two-piece design where you have to have
it you know sitting on your lap where
you have to adjust it separately so it's
not as nice but i do like the fact that
you can enclose the pen and hide it and
we'll take a look at pen performance in
just a bit now of course that more
expensive magic keyboard does also give
you an extra usb type-c port which
allows for pass-through charging and it
frees up your other port but with the
microsoft surface pro 8 you don't need
that because you have those built in now
as far as the actual keyboards
themselves the magic keyboard is
phenomenal it feels fantastic and the
surface keyboard also is very very good
not as good but no complaints this thing
feels fantastic for such a slim keyboard
and the same thing goes with the track
pads both are very good the magic
keyboard's trackpad has an even feel all
throughout so i think it's a little bit
better the surface pro 8 signature
keyboard has a slightly larger track pad
it is a diving board design so it's
harder to click at the top but overall
still it is an excellent trackpad that i
cannot complain about now i want to get
rid of these keyboards because of just
how differently they sit here it's hard
to record it and to make it look even
but before i do that i want to do two
things the first one is talk about how
you log into these devices the surface
pro 8 does have windows hello so it's
going to scan for my face and log me in
and the same thing with the ipad pro so
you just swipe up or just hit the
keyboard and it will unlock and log you
in now face id is a lot more secure you
can use it for payments for passwords
all sorts of things whereas the windows
hello is mainly just for logging in and
for the second part the microphone
quality and the webcam quality or zoom
quality that's what we call it now so
with the magic keyboard attached as you
guys can see i'm looking off to the side
on the m1 ipad pro i actually have to
look all the way down to the bottom left
for that camera and it's very unnatural
to look all the way there and then if
you ever look at the screen to say maybe
a document or something you're looking
away it looks awkward now of course you
could switch to the wider view from that
white front-facing camera but it still
looks kind of weird and off seeing it so
large and you kind of looking off to the
side if you look at the screen and here
is the webcam and microphones with the
surface pro 8. it has dual front-facing
microphones and a camera that's set up
in the right spot like most laptops so
it's natural for me to look at that spot
and then i can kind of glance down at
the screen look back up and i think it's
set up a lot better for web conferencing
but you guys let me know what was the
difference in terms of video quality and
microphone quality down in the comments
section below and now let's compare the
speakers the surface pro 8 has dual
front facing speakers one on each side
which is great but the ipad pro has some
amazing speakers we have quads two on
each side which sound fantastic so let's
go ahead and take a listen to which one
sounds better
all right guys you let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below and i will just say that wasn't
even a competition even though the ipad
pro doesn't sound its best when you're
holding it up that way and the speakers
are on the sides so they're not really
bouncing off of anything or towards your
face it's way louder
the bass is better it sounds better in
every single way these speakers are
insane even better than you know a lot
of laptops and everything else where
these yeah they do face you they're loud
enough
but you don't have that richness that
deep kind of sound of the bass and the
mids
so overall definitely not as good as the
ipad and now let's compare the displays
and both of these have had massive
upgrades from the previous generation
now the ipad's a 12.9 inch compared to
13 inch for the surface but you guys can
see they look different the ipad is a
four by three aspect ratio compared to
three by two so the surface is wider now
with that as far as actual resolution
and pixel density both are very detailed
and sharp but because they both have
about five and a half million pixels and
both of these are 120 hertz displays now
what is interesting is that with uh the
surface i actually had to go in go into
my advanced settings and change it to
120 hertz because it defaulted to 60 to
save battery life and that's because it
cannot dynamically change like with pro
motion that you get with the ipad pro
now this will automatically match your
content so if you're watching a video
scale down all the way to 24 hertz that
saves you battery life we'll talk about
battery life in just a bit i went ahead
and i adjusted that top camera so we can
look at the brightness and the ipad even
though it has a really crazy bright a
mini led display
as you can see it maxed out at 600 nits
which is still nice and bright whereas
the surface this thing will actually
reach up to 500 nits of brightness so
it's better than before quite a bit
better but still not as bright as the
ipad pro now where the ipad pro really
comes into its own is with hdr content
that's when it can reach a thousand it's
sustained across the whole screen
compared to 600 as you guys can see
right here and up to 1600 nits with
really bright peaks so you guys see how
that highlight right there on the ipad
pro pops out whereas the surface pro 8
just looks flat even though it's at 600
nits of brightness now not only that
that mini led display has blacks that
are almost pitch black kind of like an
oled display so we have much better
contrast and brightness and same thing
with colors we have dci p3 wide colors
on the ipad compared to srgb with a
surface pro 8 so if you care about
having the best display in terms of
colors contrast uh accuracy it
definitely is the ipad pro the same
thing goes for a reflectivity not only
is the ipad a lot brighter but the
screen on the surface is a lot more
reflective as you guys could see it
reflects everything whereas the ipad has
a really good
non reflectivity coating on it so if
you're using these outside the ipad's a
lot easier to use before we cover
performance let's talk about pens or
pencils the apple pencil is very nice
it's dense it feels high quality it
supports tapping for gestures and the
surface pen feels very lightweight feels
hollow the quality doesn't feel you know
the same but of course that's just how
it feels that what really matters is the
performance now the apple pencil you
guys know it performs great very low
latency about nine milliseconds it feels
awesome to use it um pressure
sensitivity all of that great stuff you
could tap to switch between say the
eraser so that part no issues at all now
with the surface pen it was good before
but now it's even better because of that
haptic feedback so i can press on the
button on the back
and i can use it to take a screenshot i
can press and hold to open up
microsoft's whiteboard and of course you
can customize what it does it is nice to
just have that tactile response when you
are using it apple shocked the world
including us when they put the m1 into
the ipad pro so we have the m1 in here
with 8 gigs of ram whereas microsoft has
a full-on x86 intel quad-core processor
this is the i5 also 8 gigs of ram this
has the best graphics as well not the
secure graphics so let's go ahead and
start out with the cpu benchmark and
we'll see how it compares now this does
have power mode so i did put it into the
best performance so we can see what we
get all right bam we have our results
and this is actually interesting i was
not expecting the surface to get this
high of a score
5116 and with that i couldn't even hear
the fans over our hvac where the fan
that is in there so that is really good
but of course the m1 it prevails we have
7285 which is actually low usually it's
higher than that uh but that is about 43
more powerful and in terms of single
core 1700 compared to 1300 it's about a
25 different so the m1 is overkill for
this tablet especially when you get into
software but that was actually with this
plugged in so what i'm curious about is
microsoft really going to limit this
tablet slash laptop all-in-one machine
if you don't have power let's go ahead
and run that again all right it's
loading up that seemed to take longer
than the first time so let's see and bam
look at that the score barely changed
take that all the other windows laptop
manufacturers that really limit your
laptops when they're unplugged when you
have a set to maximum performance this
is what you should get you should get
the maximum performance and now let's
compare the graphics we have the iris xe
graphics here and then of course we have
apple's a core m1 graphics in this
machine
that is fantastic so let's go ahead and
compare all right we have our score here
and it's a pretty significant difference
we have 20
792 for the m1 and then 13 281 for the
intel iris xe graphics 56
more performance with the ipad and that
was to be expected now of course you can
get better performance if you spend more
money for the i7 option now it will
still not get close to the m1 but you
can increase it if you want to spend
more money whereas with ipad you get the
m1 chip even on the base model you don't
have to upgrade to get this maximum
performance and then now we get into the
conversation of what does this
performance give you well to be honest
with m1 it is overkill but that is
future proofing for a year two years
three years even five years down the
line
whereas with this device the surface pro
8
you would want a little bit more
performance at least i would want a
little bit more performance if you're
using it as a pro device and with that
we have to get into applications and
their real world use cases because with
the ipad as many of you guys know that
follow the channel i made a lot of
complaints about it and multiple
different videos where the hardware is
amazing but the software has major
downsides and even though we have ipad
os 15 there are still lots of
limitations with the file manager um
there's multitasking limitations what
you can you do at the same time music
limitations and then of course
applications as far as the pro apps that
can actually harness all of this
performance that you guys just saw
whereas with the surface pro 8 you have
full windows 11 so any application that
you're currently using if you're gonna
upgrade to this you're gonna get more
performance than you had in the past
without limitations and you get the
better display you get the better
pen support you can do up you can
upgrade it
so what is really the true pro device
well in my opinion it is a surface pro 8
you have full windows full application
support whereas the ipad is still
limited and the only reason i say it's
not really pro or not to the same level
is just because of apple apple is
limiting this device so overall hardware
wise the ipad is better it is the winner
of this comparison in terms of hardware
you have that amazing display and you
get way better battery life as well you
get eight to ten hours of screen on time
compared to in the real world
four to six hours probably closer to the
four especially if you use 120 hertz
but this thing is not locked down you
have extra ports it's upgradable
and less expensive if you factor in the
keyboard in the pen so that is my
opinion but i want to hear your guys's
opinion as well which one of these is
the pro device which one would you buy
which one do you prefer go ahead and
check out one of those great videos over
there i'll link one of my ipad reviews
and videos as well click that circle
above to subscribe if you guys want to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers that's been max and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]